my wife works at Facebook Brian Chesky
gave a big talk the other day everything
is what did I say thanks Beth oh she
used to work at Facebook she works at
Airbnb now Brian Chesky gave a talk
because it's not good obviously yeah
it's not good at all cuz they're gonna
go public and our family was expecting a
nice little right you know it would have
been whatever anyway
yeah shareholders I'm very upset but I
think it will bounce back and Brian gave
a talk the other day he goes just
everyone think about this we started
this company in 2008 okay we have been
through this yeah we have planned for
this we expect we already know what's
gonna happen
he goes I just spent an hour on the
phone with Obama and and he like in a
cool way
and he goes uh he was like I we planned
for this not this but we planned for we
know what happens to travel industry
when bad things happen and he goes we
thrived in oh wait and oh nine you know
we were just getting started but we
started on paper the hardest time he
goes we will get through this it can
work and let's just work together and
execute and we'll come out on the other
side fingers crossed man yeah
that's a that's great you know it's
actually it's good for all businesses if
you know the more businesses that
survive and thrive the better because
that the whole economy gets impacted by
it so yeah rooting for that to happen
[Music]